good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is SCP
2467 object class
CER special containment procedures
Foundation satellites are to constantly
track the movement of SCP 2467 with
analysts and programs predicting the
movements of the object with plants in
the meteorological Bureau to divert
traffic from areas likely to be visited
by SCP
2467 in addition the scps Sunderland a
fully armed Legend class cutter will be
dispatched to patrol areas where SCP
2467 is likely to come in contact with
other vessels scps Thunderland is to be
equipped with a minimum of two rigid
bottomed motor lifeboats to Aid in
rescue of survivors of encounters with
SCP
2467 along with high impact Naval
Weaponry to Aid in discouraging the
object from attacking civilian Merchant
and Military vessels absolutely no
aircraft is to be deployed in the area
of SCP 2467 area of operation due to the
severe weather phenomena associated with
it where possible waste dumped by SCP
2467 is to be collected by Foundation
watercraft and taken to the nearest
Foundation research site for study a
disinformation campaign is to be run
following a borning and or abduction
event typical explanations to be
provided include user error sinking via
rough Seas or rogue waves Mutiny and
pirate encounters amnestics are to be
administered to any and all survivors
and Witnesses of SCP
2467 and its activities
description SCP 2467 is a large
oceangoing ship approximately 300 M in
length and 45 m in width bearing the
name plate DV TCA research Personnel
have been unable to find any record of a
ship matching the tca's description that
has been registered to any port in the
last 138 years of note is that
components of SCP 2467 come from a wide
variety of other ccraft including some
such as the Flying Bridge dating back to
at least the 1700s along with various
Naval weapons which operate autonomously
it primarily travels in deep water and
searches for other vessels in an effort
to abduct crew and appropriate cargo
before leaving the vessel a drift
weather patterns in a 5 km radius of SCP
2467 consistently display adverse and at
times violent conditions regardless of
and often in direct contrast to the the
given Ocean State at the time
observation has shown near constant
moderate rainstorms and thick fog in the
area surrounding SCP
2467 accompanied by moderate to strong
winds and slightly Rough Waters in
addition to the rain wind and fog
detailed above winds have been known to
reach speeds of over 125 kmph and waves
reaching an average Peak height of 25 M
when attempting to disable another ship
it should be noted that there there are
outliers such as a 42 M high wave
recorded on February 20 1958 whirlpools
of varying severity have been also
spotted appearing in the bow wake of SCP
2467 on multiple
occasions SCP 2467 is operated by a
maintenance crew corresponding to
approximately 75 individuals abducted
from other vessels encountered by the
object observance has shown that those
unborn SCP 246 67 tend to adapt to the
stress of their abduction and behave in
a manner described as cheerful within a
short time frame following abduction
this is believed to be a form of mind-
affecting anomaly as shown by any person
coming into contact or close proximity
with SCP 2467 for an extended period of
time 3 to 10 days depending on the
individual coming to believe that SCP
2467 is correct in its actions and will
gain a strong desire or Obsession
towards aiding it however possible
gradually this causes a degenerative
condition in the brain of the person to
the point where the individual loses any
semblance of independent thought at
approximately 4 to 5 months after
initial contact roughly every 40 days
SCP 2467 dumps a large amount of waste
bundled into a net out of a rear port in
the ship waste materials tend to be
composed of damaged or worn ship
components and tools along with food
scraps empty bottles clothing scrap
metal fuel waste and human
canavs at endom
24671 following incident
24672 Foundation Personnel recovering
waste materials deposited by SCP 2467
are to work in teams of six with a
minimum of two Personnel to monitor the
water for approaching sharks or other
Marine
carnivores adendum 246
702 known vessels currently incorporated
into SCP
2467 vessel name TCA description 16th
century ship of the line date reported
missing or recovered 2710
1745 explanation of disappearance
commandeered and presumably sunk by
Pirates Parts integrated into SCP 2467
Flying Bridge 20 cannons vessel name SV
DC bird description Merchant brick date
reported missing or recovered 08021 1750
explanation of disappearance crew taken
by Pirates Parts integrated into SCP
2467 anchor and various Timbers vessel
name HMS hu description 22 gun Privateer
brick date reported missing or recovered
1404 1806 explanation of disappearance
lost at sea Parts in graded into SCP
2467 s cannons vessel name HMS Juno
description 26 gun frot date reported
missing or recovered 1203 1880
explanation of disappearance sunk by a
rogue wave parts integrated into SC SCP
2467 three cannons and sails vessel name
SS warata description 150 M steam ship
date reported missing or covered 267
1909 explanation of disappearance sunk
in a storm Parts integrated into SCP
2467 two masts and Hull vessel name u52
description German armed submarine date
reported missing or recovered 2002 1940
explanation of disappearance destroyed
in a naval Minefield Parts integrated
into SCP
2467 Hall sections and a torpedo
vessel name Roma description Italian
Battleship date reported missing or
recovered 2009 1943 explanation of
disappearance sunk in naval battle Parts
integrated into SCP
2467 Hall sections bridge and structural
components and various guns vessel name
Ms munin description lash carrier date
reported missing or recovered 1912 195
58 explanation of disappearance sunk by
a rogue wave parts integrated into SCP
2467 Hall sections and cranes vessel
name MV darbishire description oil
carrier date reported missing or
recovered 0909 1980 explanation of
disappearance sunk in a typhoon Parts
integrated into SCP
2467 Hall vessel name SS Admiral in the
keov description ocean liner date
reported missing or recovered 2002 1989
explanation of disappearance collided
with another vessel Parts integrated
into SCP
2467 bow and
funnels vessel name FV Andrea Gale
description fishing vessel date reported
missing or recovered 2810 1991
explanation of disappearance sunk in
1991 hurricane Parts integrated into SCP
P
2467 Hall
sections vessel name USS Eldridge
description Canon class destroyer date
reported missing or recovered 1111 1999
explanation for disappearance sold for
scrap Parts integrated into SCP
2467 Hall sections 3 mk250 caliber guns
2 40 mm MK1 anti-aircraft guns 8 20 mm
MK4 anti-aircraft cannons and 3 530 mm
torpedo tubes vessel name c 2
description 9M yacht date reported
missing or recovered
1804 2007 explanation of disappearance
pilot error Parts integrated into SCP
2467 glass vessel name zapis p77
description guided missile destroyer
date reported missing or recovered 2409
2011 explanation of disappearance
decommissioned Parts integrated into SCP
2467 76 mm gun 40 mm gun 4 mm38 exet
launchers and Hull
sections addendum
24673 recent observation has shown a
whole section identified as having
originated on the SS Edmund Fitzgerald
which disappeared on Lake Superior on no
November 10th
1975 investigation into how SCP 2467
reached the Edmund Fitzgerald despite
its location in an inland lake is
ongoing clearance level
2467 3 document
24671 document
24671 in an effort to better understand
SCP
2467 particularly effects and any
notable events occurring on board the
vessel for d-class personnel trained in
sailing T
24671 to4 were provided with a small 9M
yacht launched from the scps Sunderland
and given orders to sail North with the
scps Sunderland tailing them at a
distance of 7 km with the intention of
them being boarded and abducted by SCP
2467 to observe the activities of SCP
2467 and its effects on those on board
each d-class was fitted with a helmet Ed
waterproof video camera equipped with a
flotation device and an external battery
pack rendering it capable of recording
uninterrupted for up to 3 months footage
captured was streamed directly to the
scps sunderland's observational
Department note due to the length of
this test extraneous and inconsequential
events and details have been redacted
for
brevity 1210 20 10:25 a.m. scps joyita
is successfully launch launched from the
Sunderland and proceeds North progress
in test 24671 continues without incident
or notable activity for 5
days
17102 0229 a.m. both theps Joy and scps
Sunderland make visual contact with SCP
2467 to the Northwest 2:31 a.m. strong
Westerly storm is manifested by SCP
2467 waves of an average 4 .5 to 6.0 M
and wind speeds of approximately 55 kmph
are recorded fog rolls in reducing
visibility to roughly 15 M SCP 2467
sounds its fog horn and d-class cameras
show blue lights at the location of the
vessel d2467 4 deploys fenders 0239 a.m.
SCP 2467 approaches The scps Joy upon
sight of SCP 24 67's Weaponry D2 24671
Turns The Vessel
180° and attempts to retreat from SCP
2467 0240 a.m. scps Joy order to turn
and approach SCP
2467 D2
24671 fails to comply 0240 a.m. SCP 2467
fires harpoons at scps joyita fatally
injuring D2
24672 and drawing the joyer to its Hall
a boarding party consisting of five crew
boards the joyer and attempts to abduct
the surviving d-class Personnel
resulting in the termination of D2
24671 4 and one unidentified male from
the boarding party 0248 a.m D2 24673
boards SCP
2467 is handed a chisel by an
unidentified crew member and told to
scrape rust from some panels under
threat of physical violence D
24673 complies 0310 a.m. scps sundaland
successfully recovers the scps joita
with no parts aside from supplies taken
by SCP 2467 leading Foundation Personnel
to believe it had recently boarded and
cannibalized parts from another as yet
unknown vessel note as of the events of
the
17102 all recorded events are entirely
documented by d2467 3's
camera 2310
20450 p.m. video feed shows d2467 3 is
displaying signs of distress and pushing
a trolley loaded with basic rations to
crew members of SCP
2467 All crew with the exception of
d2467 3 are audibly humming an
unidentified tune in unison 3010 201 112
3 p.m. video feed shows d2467 3 still
displaying signs of distress hauling in
a fishing net with three other crew
members an as yet unheard voice hereby
referred to as SCP
24671 seeming to come from the Flying
Bridge orders crew member Worthington to
be brought to the Flying Bridge four
crew members apprehended a young male
crew member and escort him to the Flying
Bridge which has the doors open door to
the Flying Bridge closes after
Worthington is to posited inside
vocalizations of distress produced from
the Flying Bridge are Audible for the
following 7
Days 2111
20655 a.m. video feed shows D
24673 swabbing the port side deck
showing lower levels of distress a
lighthouse on the coast comes into view
seemingly prompting SCP 2467 to adjust
its course and head into more open
Waters 3011 20 12:47 a.m. video feed
shows that d2467 3 is still showing
distress but is no longer requiring
guidance by other crew in undertaking
tasks on the ship d2467 3 is securing
hatches on the deck when a crew member
looks to the starboard bow spotting a
fishing ship identified as the grindle
entire crew safe for d2467 3 gather on
the deck equipped with grappling
and ladders as SCP 2467 is seen to
produce a very large plume of what
appears to be black smoke from one of
its funnels smoke enters the cloud cover
above producing a meteorological
reaction Heavy Rain waves up to 7 m in
height and wind reaching 70 kmph are
recorded crew of the grle seem to
request assistance from SCP
2467 both Crews work together to secure
the grle to SCP 246 7 followed by the
six crew members of the grindle being
coerced onto SCP 2467 under the pretense
of weathering the storm 0115 p.m. a crew
member belonging to SCP 2467 is seen to
produce a diving knife and fatally
assault the captain of the grindle
remaining crew members are escorted down
into a lower deck as d2467 3 and three
other SCP 2467 crew descend a ladder
onto the renle and Salvage food water
fuel Timbers and a segment of the hull
requiring a crane to lift onto SCP 2467
deck 9912
20322 p.m. video feed shows that d2467 3
is showing minimal signs of distress
laughing at an anecdote told by one of
SCP 2467 crew as she sweeps the deck D
24673 then hands her broom to another
crew member and approaches a captive
crew member of the grindle and addresses
them as they work leading to brief
dialogue transcript is as follows D2
24673 you should jump off now before it
changes you there's a big ship following
they might help you redacted name what
what do you mean D2
24673 the song gets in your head makes
you happy makes it so you want to stay
redacted name
okay okay I'll jump but you come with me
we can both Escape
03:26 p.m. d2467 3
disregards and returns to work note was
recovered by the scps Sunderland
approximately 20 minutes later and held
for Examination for a period of 6 weeks
before being administered amnestics and
returned to their
family 1512 200
0613 p.m. video feed shows that d2467 3
no longer displays any signs of distress
and now hums with the crew of SCP
2467 1812
20805 a.m. SCP
24671 orders Smith and Chi to report to
the Refuge Center video feed shows two
heavily malnourished men crew members
known to be present prior to the
Abduction of d2467 3 enter a lower deck
they are no longer seen at any point on
d2467 3's video feed or during
observation by the scps
Sunderland 2612 201 1119 a.m. SCP
24671 is heard ordering the crew to
deliver D2
24673 to the Flying Bridge video feed
confirms d2467 3 is once again
displaying severe distress and
attempting to exit SCP 2467 with haste
crew of SCP 2467 show coordinated
teamwork in d2467 3's capture
apprehending her 3 minutes and 52
seconds after SCP
24671 was hurt crew escorts d2467 3 to
the Flying Bridge with the video feed
showing the door swinging open
autonomously interior of the Flying
Bridge is obscured by an intense blue
green light and seems to cause
increasing amounts of static and
tracking errors as d2467 3 approaches
the doorway video feed cuts out as d2467
3 is thrown bodily into the doorway at
11:23
p.m. 1804 2 1219 p.m. video feed resumes
showing total darkness until the camera
abruptly emerges into a room evidently
out of a pipe on top of a pile of refuse
to be dumped off of SCP
2467 contents of refuse bin included
scrap metal empty oxygen tanks broken
tools seven body parts and a torn
d-class jumpsuit stained with blood and
other unidentified fluids the camera
lens also appears to be coated in the
same materials staining the declass
jumpsuit sounds of distress echo down
the pipe consistent with d2467 3's voice
albeit heavily distorted 12:29 p.m. SCP
2467 crew member enters the room and
manually places waste products into a
fishing net ties said fishing net closed
and pushes the net and its contents into
a port in the Floor video feed shows
Port leads to an opening in the stern of
SCP
2467 and then the water note waist net
and Camera were recovered by the scps
Sunderland at 12:45
p.m. closing statement following review
of the footage gathered and DNA testing
of the human remains recovered from SCP
2467 it was discovered that human
remains contained within the waste
collected did not belong to d2467 3
following this discovery orders were
given to collect any and all waste
products dumped by SCP
2467 in an effort to determine how long
it would take for D2
24673 or her remains to be dumped by SCB
2467 tooth hair and isolated skin
fragments determined to belong to d2467
3 were recovered on
2052 at 12:47 a.m. research concluded
that an as yet unknown process had
caused d24 673 to undergo a form of
catabolism breaking down tissue into a
liquid state lack of other remains
suggests that the resulting material was
used for an unknown purpose on board SCP
this concludes today's lecture thank you
for listening if indeed you still are
and you all dismissed
[Music]
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to
zargon bake sip o crop guy the Morgan
James Saba Irish
wwatch Lost Boy
segnar your local Foundation agent
zazaon worthy fire Dr Wolf
13 cubster Dean
Denis that loser casadia cams braded pit
James Wright Rowan
O'Brien K Knack
grimnir extra moments
123 and Swift
raw if you would like a special thank
you at the end of each of my videos and
some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com slthe vulgan thank
you